they're the ones that are harshest
against other Muslims the most leaning
against the and the moment that you
disagree with any one of their views
then they treat you worse than than they
treat the
kuf they there's no sex called again
like you mentioned which is me myself
many times they come out openly
challenge the people to bring of this
bring us the tell us what is the
cuz if you believe that are a SE tell us
what is
the I want to help Christians grow but
if Christians don't want to do that then
at least let's be allies then at least
let's be allies I have a really hard
time um talking about David wooden that
way I I know that he's insulting the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam what
in the name of RuPaul is Muhammad
doing and that's despicable it's
vile but he the man has had a hard life
I think we have to have some I guess I'm
becoming the compassionate Imam
now but the the poor guy has had a very
hard life uh he grew up in poverty
there's
a benefit to someone like young Don
becoming more religious becoming like
Christian and even attacking
Islam even attacking Islam there I know
it's it's bad I just I want to give
Destiny a gift okay yeah
um
I hope you like it it's just a small
token of appreciation
gotcha adults chick with giant
fat huge I am kind of offended by some
of the things that you said but if you
you know you said that you didn't mean
to be offensive okay I can understand
that you know I really lift my hands in
in prayer sincerely to pray to God
Almighty to heal and protect your sons
David and also to make them a source of
guidance for you and your family and I
pray that um that guidance uh will be
the gate um for all of you to Paradise
to be in Eternal
Paradise what in the name of
RuPaul together that's my sincere hope
uh for all Christians uh amen parous
against other
Muslims this is why they're rightfully
considered bootlickers they are are
agents they are notorious for
cannibalizing each other they are a
self-destructing group
The
Many this a non-muslim woman came she
said she said where is the woman I said
who are you to ask who's my
woman why ask him because it's slave M
slave master mindset
that you have to where is your woman who
the heck are you to ask with my woman if
you were a man I would do something else
to you
now brothers and sisters may Allah bless
you all this is just a video to clarify
something that which I have noticed many
people are repeating it some of the
brother brothers or s or are repeating
this evil statement or a lie a clear lie
either they are ignorant they don't know
they love the dean and they think yes uh
what we saying is true and some of them
are stubborn who hate J they are the
enemies they are evil doers who doesn't
who doesn't not love and like
see clarifying the truth and exposing
their falsehood what is the statement
that we
or me
person or the
brothers they are harsh with the Muslims
and soft with the non-believers okay the
statement how many times you have heard
it and and this statement is
a is
a stand before Allah is a pure lie and
you will be judged for it
okay alhamdulillah many I'm in the
street there's people who hate me and
when I see them I smile because me
alhamd smile with every Muslim I don't
how every Muslim is going to go Janam or
if I don't know him and he doesn't have
a c as the people claim and light is a
Cy then he's going to go Janam you know
or we have to be harsh with him no my
brothers and sisters may Allah bless you
all then even let us make that clear
Allah in the Quran categorized the
non-muslims Allah C the non-muslims some
of them you treat them nice with respect
you know take care of them look after
them as for those who wage the war
against us they want to kill us they
want to drive us out from our houses
then there's a way to do with them be
tough and harsh with them according to
sh Islam
okay
now let me make something clear the
non-muslims I mean the some Muslims the
reason I me I'm making this video Okay
the reason I'm making this video I I was
working in oon these some young Brothers
may Allah guide us and guide them
approached me and they said look why
don't you call us and speak to us and so
on so and they one of their statements
they kept repeating that are we are
harsh with the Muslims and very soft
with the the kufar these Believers and
the proof of that because what happened
in speak K
withan and Abdul Hakim I think the the
brother Abdul
Hakim so they based upon that they J us
okay those two brothers firstly I and
not every brother that has been affected
let me make that clear too this video is
full full of clarification to the
nation not every brother who's been
affected or S been affected by some
mentality some we said we we we label
them as no that's not the
way some of them
are are Muslims they love the dean and
they think that the cais are against the
Muslims or they don't care about the
Muslim suffering and so on because I
know this the way of the because I knew
them from before I used to hang around
with them before you know I know them
very well some of I was one of them they
used to bring me videos showing the
suffering of the Muslims and they say
look at sis they speaking against us
because we care about the Muslim
suffering mean the they do care and that
is not true whatsoever you know they
care about their party and the agenda
the sh some of them as we have mentioned
they sincerely care but some of them are
they using the suffering of the Muslims
to misguide the Muslims and to C their
party the misguided party so let me make
that clear some of them we we don't
they've been MKE as we have mentioned
they've been deceived so what we do we
speak to them I spoke toan we spoke
todim ABD privately and we clarified to
him and he accepted for two hours he
accepted it is true why while he while
he was saying us listen I accept it's
true just give me time to think yes
you're right this and that he's calling
to his misguidance he's misguiding the
youth young Brothers in the par and
calling them to Isis and call them to
the kaish so it's upon me now to expose
him openly because I care about my
Muslim brothers and sisters these guys
are in Britain while they sending Young
Brother since 15 and 16 to Syria and
their parents even know why don't you
send your daughter send your sister 15
16 to
Syria and our mothers and our fathers
crying they don't know where's my
daughter G she's 15 oh she's in Syria
got married Subhan Allah this Islam is
against Allah and his
messenger so we we we we open our arms
like this brother let us talk take my
number alhamdulillah take my number I
have no problem we talk I have no
problem you know and I don't just attack
someone and just say even if I see he's
being stubbing here and there it takes
time it takes time for someone to listen
and understand you know all of us if you
come from different backgrounds sopia
sometimes maybe you think you know what
that is not clear let me think about it
I will debate you about this you know no
problem with that we be patient okay but
if I noticed that you are not you are
Tred to deceive Us by claiming that you
agree with us yeah give me time let us
talk about this talk about that while
you are to Mis guidance then that's when
I step
in and openly I expose you and I don't
care that's how I do it openly but if
you come even the Shia people not just
the people been affected by the even the
Shia even the Christians or I said look
come let us talk let us have discussions
because our main target my brother and
sisters not to expose my brother in
Islam or my sister in Islam meaning
those who are called openly or been
affected by the mentality no our main
target is to clarify the truth for
someone to come back to De of Allah and
follow the truth you know we do it in a
good
way but I've noticed those guys so don't
judge us based upon that we do advise
them we do speak to them nicely even the
Shia people I used to come and advise
them and speak to them and but not if I
notic they are stubborn and they are
been call us they are calling to the
misguidance then we not expose them now
about the non-muslims say the
non-muslims me personally I made a video
I said don't speak to anymore don't
speak to Bob anymore those guys that
insult
our but yet there's still some brothers
who accus me that don't care about they
still speaking
to what his name B and joke with him and
hug him and smile with him alhamdulillah
Allah knows what is in the heart Allah
knows knows who are fake and know who
are real alhamdulillah
loving and defend the I said don't speak
to these guys those guys and I mention
speakers one of the the dangerous
effects of speakers K can kill your
feeling toward having the the the
jealousy of the honor
of yes I'm not going to harm you
physically cuz I'm going to follow the
law however I'm not going to speak to
you anymore because you are evil man and
about cuz people say this guy is not
even around anymore C you speak to me
and you say yes sorry for this yes and
what I've noticed this person no he's
playing around that's why I said I'm
free from you and I'm free from him
before anyway he's open his guidance you
know I never been his allies but you
know to give said let us go to
Birmingham so my brother and sisters
this is K open my arm and come to the
you know I'm hiding aldah I'm everywhere
come and speak to me say look like these
guys they said one of them said to me
may Allah guide us and guide him he said
I said against muj muj those who fight
for the the sake of allaha to defend the
Muslim owner and so on that's a big sin
you know but who are I are not mu my
brothers I not because I've been
watching the Western Media or Arab media
no I I have Insight informations about
them alhamdulillah people were been
killed because they agree didn't agree
with them when they wen't there at the
beginning because at the beginning even
in this country they were allowing
people to go and help the Muslims in
Syria but afterward they were exposed
that's why even people in the beginning
they were going to help the Muslims they
thinking these guys are helping the
Muslims but when it was clarified to
them they left you know so I hope this
video is clear to my brother and
sisters Allah love my brother s Islam
even if they disagree with them I would
still love them to make stuff clear for
them because how many people have
forgiven even they differ with me but
because
of I'm not going to hold Grudge but when
it comes to de I believe when I see
clearly you are misguiding the Muslims
then I have to clarify the
truth and I will still open the doors
for you come in private we talk us
clarify but I expose you misguidance you
know I hope that is a clear to my
brother and sisters in Islam this is
that has been spread it's been repeated
and we have always also it's my advice
to my brothers and sisters that not
every person been affected by some
ideologies from the a Muslim from these
who have been deceived who go label them
and boycott them now be nice to them be
good to them advise them but if you
noticed especially these followers of
Isis if you know this guy know he's not
just a follower he's a supporter he's a
Defender recruiter then expose him
expose him to the people even as the
said our scholar said even if you know
this person he's he's an evil guy he's
not listening he believes as to kill
non-muslims in a train not just in a
non-muslim as mentioned Isis followers
Isis these people mentality they don't
not discriminate they will even kill the
Muslims children in the train station
they don't care so then when you expose
them and report to the authority but
those who have been deceived and list
cuz I used to be one of them in the
beginning you know I used to love the
yes J J clarifi this not J yes we
believe in Jihad is an honorable act but
Jihad was not legislated to bring about
corruption to kill innocent people you
have a British passport you're proud of
it you travel everywhere you know with
it then you say I'm in the land of the
kuf I'm in the land of War so I'm going
to kill them when you have a contract
with them or Visa or independ to remain
that our teaching of Islam my brother
and sisters may Allah guide those who
have been misguided and I repeat again I
gave these brothers my number call me
alhamdulillah come we talk if you
seeking the truth come alhamdulillah cuz
I used to be affected by this evil
mentality before and I left ald I'm free
from it alhamdulillah cuz I've noticed
it's based upon emotions so may Allah
bless you my brother and sisters Islam
and you can watch my videos when I'm
harsh with Bob I didn't even want to
shake his hand B he said shake my I said
no this evil hand that hit my brother in
Islam I'm going to shake it likewise
other people but sometimes even the
heads of them sometimes as the mention
even the heads of them if you know that
maybe because why you try and if you
know they're not listening you know then
you take a different way may Allah bless
us and may Allah make us from those who
follow Prophet Muhammad wasallam
inwardly and
outwardly